It's time for you to start
working on your own weather app.
We've given you a bit
of a head start and
created the basic app shell, styles,
and initial JavaScript for you.
See the instructor notes below for
information on how to download and
get your development environment set up.
Because we'll be working with
a service worker in a bit and
service workers do not work when
served from the file system.
Make sure that you're working
from a local web server
in your development environment.
See the instructor notes for
some more ways to do this.
Service workers must
be served over HTTPS.
But to make development easier,
that requirement is waived when
they're served from local host.
When you've got everything
setup properly,
your app should look like this.
Be sure to compare your app in
the link to the instructor notes below
to make sure everything
works exactly the same.